en este vídeo hablaremos de lo que es el
gradiente y digamos lo único que vamos a
hacer en este vídeo es ver cómo
calcularlo y ya después en los
siguientes vídeos te daré la
interpretación geométrica de lo que es
el gradiente y en realidad yo yo odio
hacer esto de primero mostrar el cálculo
antes que la intuición geométrica pero
es que el gradiente es una de esas cosas
raras en donde la forma en la que lo
calculamos parece que que no tienen nada
relacionado con la intuición geométrica
y ya veremos en los próximos vídeos cómo
es que esto se relaciona pero para poder
hacerlo necesitamos saber antes ambos
así que digamos que tengo alguna función
ok vamos a vamos a poner alguna función
digamos una función con dos entradas una
f de equis y digamos que ésta sea x
cuadrada por el seno de ella muy bien
esta será nuestra función
ahora vamos a calcular el gradiente de
esta función y el gradiente simplemente
es como como una forma de juntar toda la
información de las derivadas parcial
de la función así que vamos a calcular
las derivadas parciales primero
si calculamos la derivada parcial de
esta función con respecto a la variable
x bueno aquí lo que tendremos es que ya
es una constante verdad y por lo tanto
seno de ye será como una constante así
que nada más derivamos x cuadrada y nos
da 2x y multiplicamos por nuestra
constante verdad que es el seno de iu
ahora consideremos el la hace la
siguiente derivada parcial que sería la
derivada parcial de nuestra función con
respecto a la variable y en este caso x
cuadrada es una constante verdad y sólo
hay que derivar seno de llega así que
queda x cuadrada por el coseno de y muy
bien entonces lo que hace el gradiente
simplemente es juntar esta información
en un vector entonces el gradiente lo
vamos a representar con un triangulito
volteado verdad a este triangulito
volteado a este símbolo se le conoce
como un habla
y el gradiente de nuestra función es un
vector en donde están las derivadas
parciales entonces digamos aquí está
nuestra primera derivada parcial sería
2x por el seno de iu y después
tendríamos x cuadrada por el coseno de y
muy bien este vector sería el gradiente
de nuestra función y quizás deberías
digamos enfatizar más que esto resulta
ser en realidad una función de valores
vectoriales verdad aquí por ejemplo
podríamos poner que depende tanto de x
como de g
entonces podremos notar que tenemos una
entrada de dos dimensiones en este caso
y una salida de dos dimensiones muy bien
y en realidad puedes imaginar que
podemos hacer esto mismo con tres
variables sólo que en este caso
tendríamos una tercera derivada parcial
verdad y entonces aquí tendríamos una
tercera salida verdad entonces en
general en general el gradiente de una
función f
simplemente es el vector que tiene como
coordenadas las derivadas parciales de
esta de esta función verdad entonces
para nuestro caso particular tiene sólo
22 dos salidas verdad la derivada
parcial respecto de x y la parcial con
respecto de sí y a mí me gusta pensar en
el gradiente digamos como una especie de
derivada total verdad porque en realidad
tenemos toda la información de las
derivadas parciales ok entonces este
este triangulito que llamamos tabla
digamos algo que es bastante útil es
pensar a este triangulito el gradiente
como
un vector de operadores parciales
digamos por ejemplo podríamos pensar
aquí
nuestro triángulo voy a poner lo mejor
y cuando hablo de un operador en
realidad es algo que le ofrecemos una
función y nos devuelve una función
entonces en este caso nuestro nuestro
triangulito verdad
en realidad lo podríamos pensar como un
vector que tiene la derivada parcial con
respecto de x la derivada parcial con
respecto de verdad y este vector así lo
podríamos pensar a nuestro vector o a
nuestro triangulito nav la verdad en
realidad podríamos pensar lo digamos
como como si fuera una una
multiplicación verdad podríamos por
ejemplo poner aquí nuestro tabla o lo
voy a hacer con otro color
en otro color pensemos por ejemplo
entonces al gradiente de nuestra función
como si estuviéramos aplicando el
operador tabla a nuestra función
efe y entonces uno podría pensarlo como
una especie de multiplicación verdad si
nosotros ponemos aquí en nuestra función
f al aplicarle el gradiente a efe
simplemente es como multiplicar esto es
verdad y pensaríamos en la parcial de f
con respecto de x y la parcial de f con
respecto de jay y obtenemos este vector
que tenemos aquí verdad y la razón por
la cual hacemos esto es porque este este
operador digamos nabla aparece en otros
contextos y ya hablaremos de otro tipo
de operadores como en la divergencia y
el rotacional y vamos a hablar de esto
más adelante verdad pero por ahora
podríamos al menos nos da como una una
forma de acordarnos cómo se calcula el
gradiente verdad pensándolo como una
especie de multiplicación ahora bien uno
podría preguntarse cuál es la dimensión
de este vector verdad entonces si
nosotros pensamos ahorita en el número
de variables que tienen
después tenemos dos pero si nosotros
tuviéramos una tercera variable
entonces el vector digamos nabla tendría
una tercera una tercera salida verdad
que sería la derivada parcial con
respecto a la tercera coordenada con
esto digamos con esto basta para para
decir cómo se calcula el gradiente y en
realidad no hay gran ciencia detrás sólo
digamos derivadas parciales que las
estamos juntando todas en un vector
ahora lo que sí es divertido es la
intuición geométrica y que de hecho es
una herramienta muy importante para algo
que veremos más adelante llamado
derivada direccional así que como puedes
ver hay muchísima diversión por delante